when I was approached to think about the
Chinese massacre I was like I know it
happened I know it was bad but that's
kind of it I only learn about this event
literally less than a year ago if you
don't know the history of your own
people you're kind of left with all this
context I really want to learn about it
and I'm excited to do so but also a
little bit nervous and scared as to how
my perspectives may change based on what
I learned today people forget that there
was a struggle and that there still is a
struggle going on today
we are standing right on Los Angeles
Street this is where the Chinese
massacre started it would have been
right there what we have now is this
plaque which memorializes what occurred
145 years ago
[Music]
Chinese have been easily identified they
were not well liked they were looked
upon as being a threat to the economy to
jobs
[Music]
right now we're standing above the los
angeles mall this is where the Elan
wagon store was for the folks were taken
right here and you know those wagons
they would was like a repair shop and so
the wagons were tilted up on one end and
then that was used as an area to drop
the rope and Lynch the person so it's
sort of ironic that right across the
street from the federal office building
is a location where the number of folks
got lynched
I keep thinking about my parents and how
they emigrated here in a different time
but if they had been here 145 years back
this is just could have been their fate
we literally just saw on the news
recently bet someone wrote an article
that they were still being yelled at for
to go back to China the fact that you
can kind of just erase such an event
like that it's kind of you can jab ulis
upsetting that you can just forget that
this happened and put a federal building
on it we are now where the Thomason
Corral was the balance of the hangings
occurred right here ironically we're
standing at the entry to the Hall of
Justice I didn't know is that that
I think Chinese Americans just don't
like to talk about that I think we like
to pretend that like Weil said
everything's okay that we've made it
we're part of the dream that could
easily happen today that does easily
happen today that same fear that same
language that saying we all look the
same mentality
[Music]
when they were reading the names every
hit of the gong it just felt so jarring
to me I would picture you know the
upright wagon in each person literally
being lynched what's that's me most when
they were reading out the names at the
candlelight vigil or how familiar the
name sounded they sounded like people
that I could know I didn't know that it
was the largest lynching in US history
I can see history repeating itself like
you see people being killed for who they
are today and that is just a sign to me
about like we're not learning as much as
we should be as humans you know you
still here oh they're taking our jobs so
how much has really changed I feel
inspired
honestly just to see the folks over at
the Chinese American Museum and everyone
that showed up to the event today that
clearly cared about history and cared
about preserving our heritage and our
culture and never allowing our
communities to forget the things that
happened to us
I feel pride now for how resilient our
people have been in our
[Music]
you